[Music]
[Applause]
did you know our galaxy has objects
called neutron stars that are just giant
nuclei and did you know that the amount
of uranium fuel needed to run a large
nuclear power plant for an entire year
is so small that it could fit under your
kitchen table and did you know that
doctors increasingly rely on nuclear
medicine techniques which go by friendly
sounding names such as PET scans or cat
scans or proton therapy what is nuclear
physics and where did it come from
during the 20th century nuclear physics
emerge from the shadow of chemistry to
become much more than chemistry for
example the Sun is not a chemical fire
Lord Kelvin in the 19th century did not
know about nuclear physics this led him
to wildly underestimate the age of the
Sun and of the earth Lord Kelvin was
wrong because to everyone's surprise the
dream of medieval alchemists has been
attained one element can change into
another the Sun changes hydrogen into
helium but it can't be done with
chemistry the Philosopher's Stone of the
alchemists turns out to be the nucleus
involving forces much greater than
anything in chemistry a nucleus consists
of protons and neutrons and these
protons and neutrons are held together
by the strong nuclear force that strong
nuclear force is a hundred times
stronger than the electric force which
holds the positive nucleus and the
negative electrons together in the atom
nuclear physics studies how the energy
changes when nuclei are combined and
when they're taken apart so let's look
which are the easiest nuclei to combine
or take apart iron with 26 protons is
the hardest to take apart it has the
greatest binding energy and so efficient
when we split nuclei nuclei
much larger than iron can release energy
when they're split up and fusion
combining nuclei nuclei much smaller
than iron release energy when they're
fused together into a bigger nucleus
hydrogen nuclei which are the smallest
provides the most energy when they're
combined that's what happens in the Sun
the biggest nuclei like uranium provide
the most energy when they're split or
fishing either way
nuclei provide the most powerful source
of energy in the universe through
nuclear fission and nuclear fusion
fission is the energy behind the nuclear
bombs that were dropped on Hiroshima and
Nagasaki the hundreds of nuclear power
plants worldwide providing electrical
power and the nuclear submarines nuclear
aircraft carriers and nuclear
icebreakers energy from fusion is harder
for humans to harness we can do it in
hydrogen bombs which use intense heat
from fish and bombs to fuse hydrogen
into helium making a thermonuclear
weapon scientists are working on the
dream of fusion based nuclear power to
provide clean seemingly unlimited power
by fusing isotopes of hydrogen into
helium but fusion is where the Sun gets
its energy for billions of years from
fusing hydrogen to helium and then later
helium to carbon and oxygen all of our
energy from solar power wind power
hydroelectricity coal oil natural gas
originally comes from hydrogen fusion in
the Sun however nuclear physics is far
far more than just a couple of
controversial applications nuclear
physics is about everything possible
that can be done with the nucleus for me
nuclear physics is much more about
studying collisions of nuclei in
experimental halls like at the Thomas
Jefferson National Accelerator facility
where I do my research and where we seek
to advance fundamental knowledge here in
this first lecture we're going to
a whirlwind tour of nuclear physics but
don't worry we'll explore all of these
topics again step-by-step later in the
course now the periodic table is great
for organizing atoms we just count the
number of protons we'll have the same
number of electrons if it's a neutral
atom and then well hydrogen is basically
one iam helium is two iam neon is ten
iam uranium is ninety-two am but each
element and each element corresponds to
a specific number of protons has more
than one possible nucleus these isotopes
what physicists call nuclides have a
different number of neutrons so if we
look at carbon carbon has six protons
carbon-12 with six protons and six
neutrons is the most common isotope so
the most stable one carbon-14 still has
six protons because it's carbon but with
eight neutrons is famously unstable but
carbon has isotopes ranging from carbon
eight with only two neutrons to carbon
23 with 17 neutrons chemists are justly
proud of the periodic table with more
than a hundred elements but nuclear
physicists are even more proud of
another table organizing over 3,000
isotopes and what's called the table of
the nuclides it shows all of the known
nuclei and more are added all the time
so there's a number of protons on the
vertical axis the number of neutrons on
the horizontal axis and the stable
nuclei go in a band from the lower left
to the upper right the stable isotopes
are shown in black and the color on the
chart tells us the lifetime of the
nucleus and so the lighter the color the
shorter the lifetime some 250 isotopes
are stable they don't decay they don't
change these inhabit the valley of
stability and 80 of the familiar
elements have at least one member one
stable isotope so for example hydrogen
has two stable isotopes one proton and
the
one proton plus one neutron helium has
two stable isotopes helium 3 and helium
four oxygen has three stable isotopes
tin has the most with ten stable
isotopes and the heaviest element with
any stable isotopes is lead with 82
protons so what would it take to
transmute lead with 82 protons to Gold
79 protons this was the dream of the
alchemists well we can't do it with
alchemy or with chemistry well we have
to do is we have to put the lead in a
particle accelerator and hit it with
some high-energy particles there'll be
some nuclear reactions some of those
nuclear reactions will knock out three
protons from some of the lead nuclei and
convert those net lead nuclei to gold
this can be done but Gold's not worth it
we use reactors and accelerators to make
much more valuable isotopes we might
make fluorine-18
or technician 99 for medical purposes
and in fact one gram of molybdenum-99
that is used to make the technician for
medical tests one gram of that is worth
tens of millions of dollars by contrast
a gram of gold is only about thirty or
forty dollars in addition to the stable
nuclides another 80 or more nuclei on
earth decay naturally some very slowly
from 1901 Ernest Rutherford and
Frederick Soddy began to notice parts of
what we now call the thorium decay chain
they found that thorium element 90
spontaneously decays into radium element
88 and then radium spontaneously decays
to radon which has element 86 with 86
protons and it continues well Rutherford
had already named the three types of
decay radiation even before there was
any evidence that elements were being
transmuted and so he called alpha
kay and an alpha decay a nucleus gives
up two protons and two neutrons
there's beta decay where a nucleus emits
an electron and one of the neutrons
emits that electron turns into a proton
and there's gamma decay where the
nucleus emits a high-energy photon a
high-energy particle of light sadi
coined the word isotope and one piece of
trivia is that HG Wells dedicated his
story about quote atomic bombs to
Frederick Soddy that story was where the
term atomic bombs came into use one more
a fact
the geology of our planet depends on
this spontaneous transmutation of
elements very slow decays of uranium
thorium and even an isotope of potassium
provide heat that keeps the Earth's core
molten the Earth's core being molten
means that the earth remains
geologically active and the continents
keep drifting this happens because these
isotopes have very long half-lives
comparable to the age of the earth the
half-life of common uranium uranium 238
is four and a half billion years
half-life is a time for half the element
to disappear the earth is also about
four-and-a-half billion years old
so about half the uranium 238 has
decayed in this time the half-life of
thorium 232 is fourteen billion years so
most of the thorium that we started with
is still here
other isotopes decay much more quickly
carbon-14 is an isotope created in the
atmosphere by cosmic rays that decays
with a half-life of just under 6,000
years now here's how we write carbon-14
in nuclear physics we write C for carbon
just like the chemists then we write the
14 on the left side of the carbon as a
superscript that's the number of all the
nucleons the protons and the neutrons
that's the atomic weight and even though
carbon always has six protons because
it's carbon we sometimes explicitly show
the number of protons so we write a six
on the left side
as a subscript and we do this because
sometimes it's nice to be reminded
especially for less well-known nuclei
and we usually subtract 6 from 14 so we
know we have 8 neutrons but for
completeness we can also write the
number of neutrons in which case we put
that on the right side as a subscript
isotopes used in nuclear medicine
diagnosis for various scans have
half-lives that range from a few minutes
to several days after one half-life half
of the original isotope has transmuted
into a different isotope after 10
half-lives 99.9% of the original isotope
has transmuted into a different isotope
this was originally quite shocking atoms
had been thought the permanent
fundamental building blocks of the
universe when Marie Curie introduced the
notion of radioactivity she was
describing properties of a new element
that she discovered this was the element
thorium but also she showed that atoms
can decay and that means that atoms are
not the fundamental unit of matter the
20th century was the first century of
nuclear physics
beginning with Rankin's discovery of
x-rays in 1899 and Rutherford's
discovery of the nucleus in 1911 since
then dozens of nuclear physics Nobel
prizes have been awarded
in both physics and chemistry nuclear
physics developed only recently because
the nucleus is so much smaller the
nucleus is 10,000 times smaller than the
atom what does that mean if the nucleus
is the size of a tennis ball about the
size of a fist then the outermost
electrons are orbiting five football
fields away so individual neutrons and
protons which we call nucleons are even
smaller
there's several times smaller than the
nucleus the size of a proton a neutron
is about 10 to the minus 15 meters
that's one femtometer which we call one
Fermi in honor of a great nuclear
physicist the
works and gluons or at least a thousand
times smaller than that wait a minute
why do we care about quarks and gluons
that sounds like particle physics well
what's the difference between nuclear
physics and particle physics both are
subatomic both use accelerators particle
physics also called high-energy physics
studies the particles themselves the
particles ooh and it looks at the forces
among them and the properties of the
particles nuclear physics studies how
the particles combine how protons and
neutrons combine to form the nucleus and
how quarks and gluons combine to form
the protons and neutrons and nuclei are
small but they contain 99.9% of the mass
of the atom so we said they're made of
protons and neutrons and the number of
protons determines a chemical element
chemists generally don't care about the
number of neutrons chemists average the
total number of protons plus neutrons
for all the isotopes in their sample and
to something called the atomic weight
for carbon that atomic weight is 12.01
protons provide the electric field that
keeps the electrons in orbit of the
atoms but the electric field pushes
protons apart what holds the nucleus
together at small scales we encounter
the strong nuclear force this affects
both protons and neutrons equally and we
need both protons and neutrons to make
the nucleus stable and the strong
nuclear force is holding it together the
repulsive electric force is trying to
push it apart and the nuclei that result
come from the interplay between these
two forces this interplay changes as
nuclei get larger lighter nuclei have
about equal numbers of protons and
neutrons but the heavier nuclei have up
to one point six times more neutrons in
order to make up for the electrical
repulsion of all those protons now the
stable nuclei we said are in this valley
of stability what
we leave the valley of stability well
there are two possibilities there may be
too many protons too much positive
charge the nucleus needs to get rid of
protons how does it do that it does it
by something called beta plus decay the
proton decays to a neutron plus a beta
plus that's actually a positively
charged electron called a positron which
is the antiparticle of the electron and
a neutrino so proton can decay to
Neutron positron and neutrino or a
proton can combine with an electron to
become a neutron plus a neutrino and so
we've changed a proton to a neutron the
other possibility is there may be too
many neutrons that means they're not
enough protons and so there's beta minus
decay where the neutron decays to a
proton plus an electron plus an anti
neutrino nuclear waste is basically a
problem of excess neutrons in the
fission products compared with the same
number of neutrons in the original
uranium or plutonium as sufficient
products decay they change neutrons to
protons and they move up and to the left
on the chart of the nuclei towards the
valley of stability the drip lines are
the outer limits of stability of nuclei
they're the maximum number of neutrons
you can have for a certain atomic number
more neutrons in that the neutrons drip
off or the maximum number of protons you
could have for the same total number of
protons and neutrons if you have more
protons than that the protons just drip
off
what else does nuclear physics consider
nuclear physics also studies where
nuclei come from the nuclei from
hydrogen to helium were made in the Big
Bang nuclei from helium to iron are made
in stars and heavier elements from iron
all the way up were made in supernovae
and neutron star collisions this is why
scientists like to say that we're all
really made of starstuff
there are 3000 nuclei on the chart of
the nuclei but only a few hundred that
we've detected on the earth the other
90% of the
no nuclei have already vanished from
Earth because they decayed away their
half-lives were too short and we only
know about them because we've been able
to create them in a laboratory so when
we make new isotopes were making star
stuff and even the most exotic nuclei
hide near a drip line so would have a
very short half-life may have been part
of an unrecognized decay pathway to the
formation of elements that do persist
and so nuclei no longer found on Earth
may turn out to have been very important
to our very existence how do we study
nuclei well we study them like a
five-year-old studying a mechanical
alarm clock we hit it hard and we see
what comes out well to hit it hard we
need a very small which is to say a
subatomic hammer and we use a variety of
large accelerators to accelerate
different types of hammers we can
accelerate electrons we can accelerate
protons we can accelerate other nuclei
and then we take those hammers and we
pass them through a target containing
the nuclei we want to study or modify
and we use large particle detectors to
measure the individual some atomic
particles or nuclei that emerge from
these collisions we reconstruct the
subatomic collisions using energy and
momentum conservation
just like we reconstruct car crashes to
find out who is at fault
the difference is collisions between
cars damage the cars sometimes severely
subatomic collisions can make new nuclei
it can knock nucleons out of a target to
make smaller nuclei or we can combine
two nuclei to make larger ones for
example if we accelerate zinc and we hit
lead with zinc just right we could
create bigger nuclei we could create a
nucleus called copernica so we take lead
with 82 protons and 126 neutrons so 208
total nucleons and hit it with zinc with
30 protons 70 total new
leon's we could make a per nakum with a
hundred and twelve protons and 277 total
nucleons and that's how we make either
the very heavy or the unstable nuclei
well we study nuclei because we want to
learn how the world works
and in fact the average American pays $2
per year for basic nuclear physics
research and what we get from that is a
combination of basic knowledge and
useful application understanding nuclear
physics lets us develop more
applications we can use external beams
beams of x-rays or protons or we can use
internal radioactive isotopes for
medical imaging using isotopes like
technician 99 or for medical treatment
for killing cancers we can also use it
for other purposes we can use it for
industrial archaeological and art
analysis we can x-ray samples we can use
neutron activation analysis we can date
it with radioactive isotopes such as
carbon-14 and others now let's look at
the structure atoms are made of
electrons orbiting the nucleus nuclei
are made of nucleons neutrons and
protons orbiting each other nucleons
like electrons obey a fundamental rule
two identical particles cannot occupy
the same state at the same time we call
this the Pauli exclusion principle
because of the Pauli exclusion principle
electrons stack up in orbitals there are
s shell orbitals pea shell orbitals D
shell orbitals in atoms and the Pauli
exclusion principle says no we can't put
all the electrons in the s shell you
can't put more than one particle in the
same state similarly protons and
neutrons occupy similar s shell P shell
D cells in nuclei just in a different
order so just like atoms nuclei can be
in excited States and then they
de-excite by emitting a photon when an
atom D excites it goes from an excited
state back to its ground state it gives
off light often
simple light when a nucleus D excites
from an excited state down to a ground
state it gives off a gamma ray just a
higher energy photon so one of the most
important applications of this is
technician 99 that we use in nuclear
medicine is actually in an excited state
and it decays to its ground state giving
off a gamma ray and we use that gamma
ray to see what's going on inside the
body now
well the strong force is the most
important nuclear physics makes use of
all four of the fundamental forces of
nature we use gravity electricity and
magnetism the weak nuclear force and the
strong nuclear force now it may be
surprising that gravity is important for
nuclei it's the most important force at
large scales right it's what attracts us
to the earth but on smaller scales we
don't even notice it there's no there is
a gravitational attraction between you
and the person standing next to you but
it's almost impossible to measure and so
on really small scales on subatomic
scales it's the weakest force it's less
than a billion billion times as strong
as the electromagnetic force now what
gravity does is it affects everything
with mass and it's crucial for neutron
stars neutron stars are the biggest
nuclei there are they've got about 10%
protons 90% neutrons the mass is one to
two times the mass of our Sun but the
radius is only about 10 kilometers or
six miles that would be a very short
daily commute and what neutron stars do
is there something called the neutron
degeneracy pressure they're pushing
outwards and this is because of the
Pauli exclusion principle and gravity is
pushing in and so it's the balance of
gravity and this neutron degeneracy
pressure that determines the features of
neutron stars the next force is
electricity and magnetism and where it
primarily affects us in nuclei is that
the protons in the nucleus repel each
other
and then of course it attracts the
electrons to the nucleus to four
atoms and the range of the
electromagnetic force is very long so it
extends over the whole nucleus and so
every proton in the nucleus can repel
every other proton and it's the
electromagnetic force that's responsible
for that gamma radiation that we just
talked about
then there's the weak nuclear force this
affects all particles now you might
think that this is a misnomer because
the weak nuclear force is stronger than
gravity at very short ranges but we call
it the weak nuclear force not in
distinction to gravity but in
distinction to the strong nuclear force
the weak nuclear force is transmitted by
particles exchanging these massive
particles called the W and Z bosons you
may have heard of those each half a
hundred times the mass of the proton and
so it's like instead of pushing your
friend away from you you push your
friend away by throwing a medicine ball
at him or her that's exactly how this
exchange of massive particles works but
because they're so massive the weak
force has the smallest range of all the
forces and we're saying well wait a
minute what is the mass of this exchange
particle have to do with the range of
the force well it comes in through the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle says
that the uncertainty and the energy
terms the uncertainty and the time is
going to be about the size of Planck's
constant
well the uncertainty and the energy
comes from the energy we need to create
in order to make this massive particle
and the uncertainty and the time is how
long that massive particle can exist so
the uncertainty in the energy is really
big because the particle is very massive
that means the uncertainty in the time
is going to be very small that means
that particle can't travel a long
distance it can only travel a short
distance and so the range of the weak
force is 1/500 the radius of a proton
very very very short this weak force
doesn't help hold the nucleus together
but instead it can change protons into
neutrons or vice-versa through beta
decay if the nucleus is
on the slopes of the valley of stability
now free neutrons are always unstable
because they're slightly more massive
than protons and they decay by the weak
force into protons so a neutron free
Neutron goes to a proton plus an
electron and an anti-neutrino what about
neutrinos
well neutrinos are produced by beta
decay they've got no charge and very
little mass they only interact
incredibly weakly but we care about them
in nuclear physics because amazingly
enough it's the pressure of these
neutrinos that make supernovae explode
the strong nuclear force that forth
force is the most important of the
forces for this course at a fundamental
level the strong force holds the quarks
together into protons and neutrons the
same strong force also leaks out of the
protons and neutrons to hold the protons
and neutrons together into nuclei this
is just like the way that neutral atoms
attract each other to form molecules
they do it through the electric force
that leaks out well how does an electric
force leak out of an atom atoms are
neutral the negative electron balances
the positive protons helium is a closed
shell symmetric so very little force
leaks out because you've got the
symmetric sphere of electrons around the
proton and so helium and other noble
gases are inert but if we look at sodium
it looks like there's a symmetric core
with one electron orbiting and so that
means that we've got this sort of
positive core and negative electron and
so a lot of the electric force can leak
out and sodium is very very reactive so
the same thing happens with protons and
neutrons the three quarks form a proton
and then the force that leaks out of the
proton is what attracts it to other
protons and other neutrons so what about
these quarks well they've got colours
instead of charges we call them red
green and blue and because it's colours
we call this force quantum
chromodynamics chromophore color the
force is carried by particles called
gluons and at
very strong force so the neutrons and
protons are made of three quarks each
mostly but only 2% of the mass of the
proton or neutron comes from the quark
masses this is a 2% that's explained by
the Higgs boson in nuclear physics we
aim to understand the other 98% of the
mass the full quark structure of the
nucleon is very complicated I said there
are three quarks but there are also
quark antiquark pairs and gluons and in
fact the closer we look the more quarks
and antiquarks we see nuclear physics
has only started to apply quantum
chromodynamics directly to an entire
nucleus instead of just to a proton or
neutron in the second decade of the 21st
century we're just starting to learn how
the quark structure of protons and
neutrons changes slightly when they're
in nuclei instead of by themselves now
the force between the protons and the
neutrons can be described as being
carried by a particle that's a thousand
times lighter than the particles that
carry the weak force and so the fact
that it's a thousand times lighter means
that the range of the strong force is a
thousand times longer than the range of
the weak force why does this matter
well to interact a high-energy particle
has to hit its target
within the range of the force and that
means that a weakly interacting particle
has to hit a circle with a radius a
thousand times smaller and the area of
this circle is a thousand times a
thousand is a million times smaller this
means that the strong force is about a
million times stronger than the weak
force atoms change we now know in three
fundamental ways there's alpha decay
when the strong force can't hold the
nucleus together
there's beta decay which converts
protons to neutrons or vice versa via
the weak force and there's gamma decay
which is a release of excess
electromagnetic energy in the next
lecture we'll explore more closely how
the interplay of the electromagnetic and
strong forces makes the nuclei we know
[Music]
[Music]